- Ya'll is very spicy.
(vocalizes)
Ya'll was the hot sauce.
- [T.I.] I was waiting for it.
- And everybody else was the chicken wing.
(laughs)
I'm expecting to get pregnant
by one of these records.
That verse definitely
gave me trust issues.
(laughs)
I don't trust ya'll men.
Ya'll just, I just, you know what?
Pour me something real.
(laughs)
(laughs intensely)
I really wasn't feeling that murder thing.
You know that scares white people.
(grumbles)
You literally hanging by a vagina hair.
You know that little hair on your lips
that you didn't get to?
You're that hair.
(laughs)
- Yo
- Take my panties off.
(vocalizes)
You smoke weed, don't you?
(laughs)
You do!
There's a lot of competition.
And I don't understand
what's wrong with hummus.
I like hummus.
(laughs)
- [T.I.] Chance?
- You put your feathers in my drink, girl!
- [Cardi B] Oh snap!
Getting spicy!
(vocalizes)
Do it again! Do it again!
If I was blind, I couldn't
even believe you rap like that.
You know what I'm saying
You look like you build
computers but you did good.
(laughs)
- Shit getting tight!
- Yeah.
- Tight like my butthole.
(laughs)
- Yeesh!
- These kids nowadays
they wanna see nipples, colorful
hair, tattoo on the face
I don't know.
I get nervous!
- But you Cardi B, you don't
give a fuck about nothing.
- I do, I do. I be geeked up.
I be like oh my god.
(mumbles)
(laughs)
I did done perform with nothing.
Just myself rocking the crowd.
- [T.I.] That's right.
- Popping my pussy.
(laughs)
I'm selling boobs. I'm
selling ass and everything.
Well the way that Flawless came up there
like a male stripper that works at
(laughs)
- [T.I] He was selling
that shit, wasn't he?
- He looked like he was
going to come in there
with a pizza box without the pizza in it.
(laughs)
Yeah you just didn't give me that "eh!"
Am I gonna remember you later
on when I'm getting fucked?
No.
I didn't know you were really up first
because you know when I saw you
you looked like you was
gonna mop some floors.
(laughs)
What is you drinking in there,
That's liquor?
I think I need some.
(vocalizes)
I have messed up before
but I ain't gonna show it though!
(vocalizes)
She look like she read books for fun
I don't know who read books for fun.
Thank you Jesus because
I was scared for the boy.
I would make love to this song.
(laughs)
It's going to be litty
like a fucking titty.
(laughs)
Ya'll don't understand like
after this I got a date
and I'm not gonna enjoy my date.
(laughs)
Like I'm not going to be able to have sex.
I'm not going to be able
to eat and I know that.
- You'll be fine!
- I swear to God!
Order in the court room!
God damn it!
Mm, I hate to be the bearer
of bad news but I am.
I ain't understand you.
(laughs)
I mean I heard my name and I was like.
Eh, Comme Si, Comme sa.
That's french by the way.
That song wouldn't sell though.
Not going to L.A.
You could go to Jersey!
(laughs)
We gonna overcrowd Jersey you know.
He is going to
- Peoria, Illinois.
- He going to Peoria, Illinois.
- But ya'll didn't say it
like ya'll really liked it.
I really liked that video.
- I liked it.
I loved the video.
I was like "ah!"
You impressed me with
your little white ass.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
Oh! I already like it!
(laughs)
You know you really surprised me
because you look like
you work at Best Buy.
I like your song.
I was like pop that pussy
for a fifty cent soda.
Okur!
You know what Fat Joe,
Big Pun, Rick Ross, Biggie
all have in common?
They have this confidence
and they have this swag
that makes skinny niggas wanna be them.
That make bitches wanna lick fucking icing
off they fucking stomachs.
I said what I said.
- [Chance The Rapper] Okay, all right.
- You really, you got
me fucked up right now.
(applause)
- This nigga's crazy!
What the fuck, bro?
What happened?
- I wish I could tell you.
- Did ya balls froze
'cause everybody here?
You know I blew up on social media,
and maybe you can too.
(laughs)
You know it made me wanna like "aye!"
You definitely came in there
like you put some baby oil on today.
You know what I'm saying.
You came in there.
I'm not a person
that flirtatious or something
- You not?
- I'm not!
- Who are you and what
have you done with Cardi?
- I'm not like I'm an emotional
gangster you know like.
(laughs)